he wants his own team doing that there's
a jackie chan hacky sex scene man if you
haven't seen that no
huge thanks to keeps for sponsoring
today's episode stick around to the end
to see how you can get 50 off the best
way to keep the hair that you already
have
good morning happy saturday we are on
the couch and you know what that means
another episode of step memory acts
today we have a special guest a super
legend andy chang andy tell the audience
about yourself i am from hong kong china
security stunt team i do stun my direct
i coordinate so that's who i am he's
being very humble right now yes he's
being very very humble i'm over here
shaking in excitement same same
this man is responsible and was a part
of some of my favorite movies as a kid
and still some of the best action in my
opinion today even today yeah it's wild
today you are still prominent in the
enjoyment that i go to the movies for so
i'm so happy and thankful for you to be
here sir thank you have me here
you guys knew talent you know well
that's just an old man
well we're going to learn a lot from you
today oh yeah we're going to start off
with inspiration andy has a really cool
story with a particular film that we all
know and love and have spoken about on
the show a bunch of times police story
this is cool it's so crazy
this moment we're watching just like far
away from the building because they're
blocking the road we cannot go get close
you know because you know they they're
filming so you're standing on the
sidelines watching this how old were you
when you were watching this like 12 13.
wow so you're a 12 13 year old boy on
the side of the road behind the blockade
yeah watching this unfold from the side
of the street watching them do this
stunt jackie chan film that is classic
this is amazing yeah
and then this is very cool you know all
the people we see him jumping and then
that's my backyard right we're seeing
all the we
we play around there you know and then
after that remember all the car come
down to the end and you just hear
ambulance ambulance ninjas you know yeah
this is a really ambulance there that
moment it's like i've seen this wow this
is something the filming movie but i
don't understand that moment too young
but then we go see the movie this moment
he's running down this hill this huge as
well i go up you know we have a
cardboard and slide down the hill this
hill exactly this hill we're going to
put the cardboard and there's a slide
from the top and then we will find a way
and a little rock and coming back and
then slide again so as a kid this was
your playground that's my taekwon and i
said this is what we're doing like him
doing but we never really do one thing
we slide with the butt right yeah one
thing i can do i think i can do it
since after that i'm in high school i
see that and then i say i want to do a
movie next day i skipped the scoop you
were so i
i call all the fans say hey how i can do
movie and then someone said okay you can
come to do a background so i go to do
background waiting all day
and at the end of the day
i remember the pa say okay okay come
here you go into this store and buy a
coca-cola pretending buy a coca-cola so
i walk in i buy a coca-cola and then i
walk out and then i said this is what i
do i want to do fight i want to do
action movie you're like where's the
action i'm ready yeah
wait i skipped all day i just waiting
for that i said oh i'm not doing movie
yeah i'm not doing this you know so then
i do have condo and then i become a
champion and whatever you know
no big deal
that's cool i can do it i do fight
scenes at that moment i get into the tv
company and then i do almost seven years
in the tv company as a stuntman actor
and trying to learn everything as the
movie and then somehow someone called me
for mr nice guy that's amazing and then
jackie chan's stunt team from that point
from that point yeah jackie's instant
team let's take a look at uh mr nice guy
fight here
you already see all the white people
doing you know the caucasian people
doing the fight but then you suddenly
this is me
this mean falling down but then when
they close up
so that's me chase it this is see yeah
wow dude i never even knew that we keep
switching because jackie is not really
he's very particular yeah
the stun team so yeah he trusts the stun
team you know if he don't feel
comfortable then you just acting right
he was just okay somebody double him and
then also the timing you know sometimes
right you have to be perfect right yeah
yeah
timing so you have the good timing
coming you late you know you're early
it's all about timing you know i like
watching this in the theaters as a kid i
did not you never know
i didn't even know until just now my
mind's blown yeah that's amazing a lot
of people know why he's always have a
stun team it gives the better
so you're not worried you will everybody
knows okay he likes to work on full
beats or half beats and then everybody's
able to dance completely together rather
than a day player who shows up from a
different stunt background coming in and
being like hey i'm coming in and i'll do
this fight scene and jackie's like you
don't know my language and how we speak
and how i how i move yeah there was a
whole moment on the rooftop fight right
you're just talking about the kick the
kick and he's like the timing's off and
we need to switch right
so we can changing it because he wants
his own team doing that because he knows
they can go that fast oh somebody really
could this uh
yeah yeah so that's we picked him and
then he sees her talent we say wow this
boy is tough you know he's not just
tough he has really good skill tumbling
wushu
[Music]
that's not bread that could do a fight
for him
for him yes that's the bread bread is
the one stuffed
yes
that's bread he's stuck in there from
that on everyone know like it's a stunt
community you know where ellen you know
like this star wars secondary direct you
know it's the kingsman you know
kick ass you know hellboy is amazing
success is preparation meets opportunity
so we are constantly preparing for the
moment just like myself i'm still
training for that one day that i get
called up to be a part of jackie chan's
stunt team
uh i hope for it's coming yes
it's coming my next project training
training training yeah
that's okay we'll just say he tried to
catch a cab
no she's about to blow it all up you
turn that mama right now dude yes you
crazy man ain't jumping
crazy
[Music]
i think that the building had wow 16
yeah 16 and then halfway this is like
right yeah
yeah extraordinary activity job oh
that's the activity job quick release
into boxes no no just straight oh yeah
straight no swing
and then this one looping the pie this
is a very dangerous thing
yeah because you guys oh if you caught
you cut the wire you're gonna hit the
pie yeah you could be
die
oh this is the best right here
oh my god these two movies man
just perfection so
break this down for us how did it set up
doing this because this is crazy you
have explosions here you have wire gags
it's never been done you cannot
really rehearsal it it's right because
we're in the las vegas photo first so
they do the daytime testing without
blocking the road but they're testing
with the same bed but the same bed it
doesn't successfully
they break the sandbag they have all the
dummy arm everything fired off and then
that job is lucky you make a loop you
feel the momentum
so nobody can stop that if anything
happens nobody can stop it we just hit
it hand there and it's just a girl yeah
wow so risky yeah these are all fifo if
you could control it's more worse right
maybe four because you want to let the
momentum you want that momentum so
that's why they just quick release and
then you just swing it like a yo-yo man
i'd be doing everything in my ability to
make sure i loop around i'm kicking my
feet
so when you were doing the tests with
the sandbags and whatnot you knew that
that structure the pull it was sound
right like it wasn't going to break yeah
they don't break they check it right you
check it they built it where they they
do you build it okay beautiful they have
to have that solid to make the loop if
this bouncing then this looping right
they have the spinning on the bottom but
they lock it the mixture will loop and
then they're spinning the sideways
wow boom now now they get dropped
yeah yeah now they rotate that wow but
when we're doing they're just locking so
make sure they're sorted so the looping
can happening what about the whole slide
down like you you're on
wheels slide is kind of like a super
idea so we have dead man we know where
we stopped at so this explosion and then
with that man we stopped there because
they have tingling there and then
they're talking it's very complicated it
looks like they're easy but
and then when you're dropping like 84.
you know that's the fee for that's so
think about it the gut the gut feeling
of it is so wild the butterflies yeah
and this part is all in one there's
nothing it's not this is all different
camera but they're all in one shot right
one take one take one
one take you see that is it like a lucky
thing you know
very few times you get to do one take
and this is definitely worthy of yeah we
don't we don't revisit this we just we
got it
one big deal i cannot believe five foot
ten thousand miles for this [ __ ]
god dang oh it's so great masterful what
a great movie i think when it comes to
story and action and comedy rush hour
one and two is like my favorite
hollywood's best and it's all thanks to
a group of guys from hong kong
the
yeah
if you guys are learning something and
you're having your minds blown just like
myself and you're not subscribed it's
time to subscribe
let's get back to it
[Music]
oh shoot wires no no no no this fight
scene same thing there's a nikki right
right but the guy is a big guy he's not
right not nikki we keep switching
everyone you can tell because the suit's
like huge on him yeah
it's great you don't tell you know you
just like it seems like it's just the
most efficient way to put the scene
together you see this how careful he is
this is the scene with shooting
somewhere else but he know he want to do
the clocks yeah so in the fight scene
earlier he'd do this part and take off
his blue shoes yeah i like how they're
all choices it's all storytelling from
him that's perfect so he now he already
established himself no shoes
[Music]
he runs into a thing of shoes that's
great that's why i love his fights so
much is there's storytelling mixed in
and there's character mixed in it's not
just a brawl
[Music]
this is very complicated i am the one
he have to kick it and then they have to
wipe that to my face oh my god and he
had to do the 360 jump again and then
land on step on my both feet
dang
so sick so i know they did this so many
times yes yeah 65 70 something so after
40 some take he swapped me to doubling
our team apollo he said okay andy go
change i thought he said he tired be
doing too many spinning cake i change
you to to do
yeah
no no
double paw
then the funny part is like sometimes
it's not just missing something hit it
but he forget it he did this dude
so then we finally make it but if today
it's much easier it will be cg the soos
but you appreciate it so much more when
it's not it's a foam shoe right here
yeah but it's to have all the timing and
everything everything right here
and then he had to do this yes all one
shot right and he's very stubborn but he
really believed him he know he can do it
it's a perfectionist it's just that
somebody can help or whatever you can
catching you know he would do it and
that's what makes himself give up you
know that's a lot of money you know we
stand on the street walking you know for
12 hours right but he had a history you
know he did the similar like this in the
hockey exec
you're talking about a scene yeah
there's a jackie chan hacky sex scene
man if you haven't seen that no
dragon is ready for the santa claus this
is old old old
i've never seen this yet this is like
i'm all about this
you guys don't even know how much about
this item
yes the stall
with the sidekick
i know for a fact a lot of kung fu
classes i've been to they use that to
warm up it's the best we do that i can
set on set all the time yeah yeah it
keeps you limber it's like it's the best
sport
[Applause]
oh we gotta shoot this we gotta do
something we have to redo this clint i'm
deep into it i know you are deep in
already dude you don't even know
actually you do know maybe i told you
yeah
this is amazing yeah i can't believe
i've never seen this man
this is like
this is my life right here son
this is it
he wanted to do that it's not the goal
of buckinghamshire he missed it he hit
the beat yeah he wanted
he want to hit the bin he does three day
for that very very very complicated but
remember then there's no cg right you
all have to do it you have to get one
thing like this perfect everyone have to
be get into it it's so difficult it's
really cool that jackie takes as much
time as he does to get the particular
stunts or even when they're not big
things like kicking a clog is not
considered a massive stunt however it
takes precision timing and a little bit
of luck and he's willing to sit there
and the production's willing to sit
there and let him get it the way how he
wants to get it right that's why
hollywood and hong kong
china the system is so different and
that moment like he's a star he's a
director right he have a lot of control
and make the decision like if he thinks
something he want to do he will spend
time and try to get it done right get it
done it's different so you won't you
will never see this thing
no i wish
that we keep going like that but
it never happened maybe we can change
that maybe something maybe somebody
could make that that change for us
because there is a new generation coming
up and there is new things that are
coming in and your expertise you still
can try that but i think we'll be like
you guys like a new filmmaker i think
it's better you know if kids are getting
into it younger and younger these days
when i was a kid i would play video
games yeah and then i would do vfx i'd
be like now kids are probably similar
but vfx is a lot more accessible
filmmaking is a lot more accessible so
as a kid you have a ton of free time
right so if you do your hobbies and you
do your passion in your free time you're
growing your value in your free time as
a kid when you don't have to worry about
life responsibilities you have to worry
about paying bills and i think the
younger that you can get into it like
when you were 12 when you were 13 when
you saw jackie coming down the hill you
know you dove in right we have chance
for the young talent right if they loved
you you just need the
the passion and then something you can
see oh i can concrete organic and try
something that's why he success right
that's why tom cool success right right
they take their time they don't give up
and then they don't give up they just
passionate about what they think
there was a tony hawk moment in his
documentary i think someone else was
saying it about him he didn't think
about the repercussions like what's the
worst case scenario right you never
think about the worst case scenario yeah
you just think about
doing it doing differently
not focusing on the what if it doesn't
work out you just focus on it working
out and doing everything it takes to
make it work out yeah i think you just
fight if you can you like you too right
you have talent
my passion yeah
it's happening yeah
camera
that's cool i feel so inspired
jake what are you up there
dude
do you see this
yes there's there's one there is one
hair that is like on an island i think
i'm experiencing some form of merrell
pattern baldness i'm right around the
age what's the age
before 35 what percentage of men
two-thirds that's likely that's so
likely man i don't think there's
anything you could do about that you
know what that's where you're wrong
jordan because with today's sponsor
keeps i can keep the hair that i have in
an easy and convenient way okay so thank
you very
much seems like you really should have
been that worried about it
you see keeps offers clinically proven
doctor recommended treatments to improve
hair growth and prevent hair loss
through subscription plans that are
delivered directly to your door
when you sign up with keeps you talk to
a doctor and they issue you a
personalized prescription plan at about
half the cost of a traditional pharmacy
how do they do that well it's very
simple they offer generic versions of
already approved fda drugs
and not only that but keeps has 24 7
access to an entire network of medical
experts and care specialists who are
there to help you make your hair goals a
reality
so whether you're looking to prevent
hair loss stimulate hair growth or just
keep the hair and take care of the hair
that you already have keeps has you
covered so if you're interested in
getting
50 off just go to keeps.com
corridor crew that's k-e-e-p
dot com slash corridor group for 50 off
or just click the link in the
description below anyways thanks for
watching this segment and uh let's get
back to those stunts
i feel like i'm in a different different
zone different world now like this was
an amazing episode it was like a true
master class seriously
thank you so much thank you thank you so
much thank you we do again right yeah
yeah yeah
we got something we only skip the
surface guys so please you guys can
check on imdb and put in the comments
below what projects andy chang has
worked on coordinated directed then
stunts in and put them in and we'll
bring them on for another episode of
stuntmen reacts and we'll look at those
projects and we'll talk more and more in
depth of what it takes to be a stuntman
of his caliber yeah let's do it yeah
maybe watching it maybe find something
oh i'm watching this movie i want to be
in the movie right we're trying to
inspire
someone next generation sit down here
yeah that would be amazing like that
that's the goal right we hope we inspire
the next filmmakers of the new
generation
of this generation they're already here
they're already here they're already
here
you guys have to do something
oh yeah always that's the goal let's go
always let's go make it fun make it fun
thank you guys thank you so much thank
you thank you for watching bye-bye peace
happy saturday happy saturday